ryan you do have a connection i i've got
a weird intro to show business via was
it your uncle i believe yeah that's
right so he
so
was your uncle living with you
yes
and did you walk into the room once
i walked into the room once and he was
um um
bedazzling a a sequined white jumpsuit
and he said that he was going to be
elvis for a little while
and and and you know what i'd like to
help and and
he said absolutely what do you need me
to do so i became his head of security
and he got my whole family in on the act
my mother was a backup singer and um
[Music]
honestly it was one of the greatest
performances i've ever seen
i mean you've been sincere i mean it was
it was really affecting
no no he yeah he i mean what i admired
about what he was doing was that he
looked nothing like elvis you know
he didn't attempt to he had a mustache
and very little hair
um
but my god he just he just became him
and uh you know he would end every show
with uh suspicious minds
and he would get on his knees and and
often with tears in his eyes he would he
would sing to some imaginary woman and
beg her not to leave
and
we were transported from this mall in my
small town
in ontario to to to that
i imagined it was a kitchen and she was
trying to leave and we were just in that
moment every night and it was
it was incredible and and honestly one
of the best like
acting lessons i've ever i ever had yeah
i wish i could have helped out with
those sequins
could use a little i would have liked
that how old were you at when you were
doing security
i want to say six
it's quite quiet
i just had two tiny guns
wait so there's no photo
no ah i painted i painted a picture bro
yeah
there's no photo there's lots of young
ryan pictures i'm googling
chris who are you uh in lockdown with uh
my dog just me and my dog at this point
is this the famous dodger yeah it is it
is he's right over there i i keep trying
to call him over and he keeps ignoring
me dodge come here
come here
buddy he was on the pistol
just looking at me and just not moving a
muscle he couldn't be bothered is dodger
real where is he
yeah where is he hang on hang on hang on
uh
i miss him he's right ready walked away
he couldn't be bothered
he's sick of quarantine he's over it
yeah it's that thing where like dogs
wanted to spend more time with you just
not this much time with you
yeah we've crossed over he's ready to
move out you're still you're still here
we're all delighted to see you dave yeah
but i don't know if you're watching
bridgeton but uh reggae jean paige you
are you i mean you're a proper foo
fighter i i'm hugely relieved you're not
in the studio i wouldn't be functional
if you were it's a pleasure to meet you
at a distance sir
no because didn't didn't you didn't you
didn't you learned playing
you're pretty much the reason a
performer entirely the first song i
learned to play on drums was let's fly
um my brother and i would terrorize my
neighbors with this on loop we'd play at
like all of our local church halls like
just because i think we've got a picture
of you reggae in your in your band here
you are look at you
look at you so cool that's that's what
you did dave you built this yeah you
built that
don't put that on me don't put that on
me
when you were making this this movie
what where where did the dog the dog
isn't in the film
you had a dog didn't you
oh no i found a dog on the uh on the
film okay
would you like me to tell that story
yeah
i can give it a go if you want
a big old dog
three legs
right yeah that's about right
no they uh
so i i was staying at this sort of go-to
movie guy house in atlanta where you
know when they showed me the the house
they were like you know liam hemsworth
and miley cyrus just stayed here so
and they gave me one of these you know
which i thought was untoward
but it was they're very precious about
the house what i didn't realize was that
there's a strict no dogs policy and then
i was going to work one morning and
there's a little dog it's minus it's
below zero and i thought oh what can it
what harm can it do
and i let it in the house when i came
back
from work it was like a fecal jackson
pollock
it was just
it was everywhere
it was like did he have help
i was like looking up like did he get a
ladder
how does he was he still alive
[Laughter]
and uh so then i had to clean it all up
and then i'd hide the dog and i spent
like two weeks hiding this dog
and uh you know when it was over the
last day i didn't know what i was going
to do with it and actually your driver
beau
said that his um his father had just
lost his dog of 16 years and so beau
took this little dog and he went and
lived on a lake with a hundred acres and
he went to you know
literally oh
that's a nice story that's a lovely
stuff yeah it is um
[Applause]
100 acres now
[Laughter]
so dead that dog
and this comes from that kind of
incredible
shonda rhimes world shonda land which
you were in shonda world sunderland
already yes uh i've been working
for shonda for the last three years
before bridgeson in a show called for
the people i've been doing a new york
lawyer for doing my best kind of fast
talking high trouser type of acting um
and shonda didn't actually know that i
was british when they were casting
bridgeton she was just like i want what
he was doing in that show but british
and then i turned up and we had our
meetings she's like wait you're you're
not american he's like no no this is
actually what i do you'll be the first
person to allow me to act in my own
accent for about six years um which was
lovely wow and i appreciate that very
much was it was great not quite my own
accent i'm a little bit more confident
so where you actually are a little bit
down yeah but
i was a bit disappointed i was like i
mean
it's a lot of effort oh very good and of
course the two of you who share a cast
mate nicola yes we do yes yes lovely
nichola yeah yeah and of course that's
why i started watching uh bridgeton it's
uh and you're one of the reasons i
stopped watching i do my best yeah
actually because i live alone and and
there's a pandemic going on and just
watching very beautiful people have a
lovely time dancing and having sex i'm
like you know i don't want to watch that
crying eating beans in my pants
[Music]
[Laughter]
but very quickly i have to say another
movie we loved you in was of course
knives out
all right that movie
i mean it just went gangbusters didn't
it that movie yeah yeah it did well i
mean people love a good murder ministry
and it's one of those genres that i
don't think has been explored as much as
maybe some other genres in films so so i
think people were really excited about
uh having one done really well and as
well as the plot you know people loved
the plot of knives out they loved the
characters
but they also loved the cable knit
sweater yeah yeah they did i you know
who doesn't love a cable net
that's my favorite thing about living in
massachusetts you get a good six-month
window where a cable knit works but no
people went mad for it it turned into
headline news everyone's going nuts over
chris evans knives out sweater chris
evans is a sweater he's getting people
hot and bothered over knitwear and i
like esquire here's how you can get
chris evans very from nice presumably
you go to a shop
it's not rocket science
well that's that's my goal in my career
to try and let some sort of prop or
inanimate object do the heavy lifting
for me and then take all the credit and
presumably you can never wear one again
you know i i i do get a little bit of
side eyes when i wear one now it's a
little bit of like oh yeah
he's wearing okay well you know but but
i i figure a couple years i i can't stay
away but someone in your family uh can
wear one
how beautiful does
dodger he hated it he hated it and he
looked so good in it but he was that
that look is a look of disgust
i think the thing he doesn't like is no
sleeves i think he feels
emasculated a cable knit vest doesn't
quite have the same appeal does it no
because brian you were also a young
entrepreneur weren't you
i wouldn't say that no
but didn't your father what did he eat
he wanted you to sell was it cellophane
you wanted to sell
my parents came upon a
truck of cellophane somehow
i was asked not to ask too many
questions i didn't
i just suddenly there was a basement
filled with cellophane and
they encouraged me to go to school and
see if i could sell it to my teachers or
put a few in my backpack and try and
hock them at recess you know
convince kids that they might be good
stocking stuffers for their parents
what are the uses of cellophane
how did it go
what do you mean what's the use of zelda
i didn't i i know the name but i don't
know what you do with it you know you
wrap sandwiches in it it keeps things
fresh oh
okay
i'm sorry no no no it was an important
question you needed to ask her
i'm not doing a good job of selling it
obviously but yeah did you did you sell
it
there's still some left if you're
interested
[Laughter]
the dream was someone would just say
i'll take all of it
never happened
it's a weird story
it is a bit weird now you tell it yes
just like that we brought the heat we
set the fire up as you're acting
overheated
i know it has gone up in flames yeah
region he is so hot
the fire alarm's gone off
i'll take that
can we please keep that in the show so i
can have it in the showroom
i mean
[Laughter]
that's why it doesn't open the door
because it'll probably be the fire
brigade
uh i'll just ch i'll just ch i'll just
check with people who know are we all
safe in our beds oh apparently we're all
good now
hey when when we heard about we were
promised it was going to be like this
you know really raunchy sexy and i was
watching it though where is the sex but
my god once you pull the rip cord it's
it's non-stop
there's a bit
i mean even you must have been kind of
you know at the table
[Laughter]
i think that's important to see on tv as
well because
that is uncommon that you see that kind
of power dynamic in rawchy scenes and
that's part of the way that we did want
to modernize the show so the duke does
have his mouthful and he's proud of it
um but yes there was there was a fair
bit um to be done on the show because
you're really going for it but you're
going for it in kind of beautiful
locations
i mean like and occasionally very
uncomfortable locations well yeah those
library steps didn't look easy um
but did you have didn't you have room
monitors in the stately homes well this
is a problem because the set as usual is
more valuable than any of the actors so
if you're in like you know a 200 year
old bed or a 400 year old four poster um
it has to have a reminder like you know
when people kind of bring very expensive
jewelry around they have to have a
bodyguard there's a bodyguard for the
room and so at all times you know you've
got this minimal set everyone gets very
quiet very respectful and you kind of
you de-robe and you hit the bed and then
there's also just like fran in the
corner who's just standing there just
kind of deciding whether or not to look
she's like i have to look i'm not
allowed to look i have to look
could you please go easy on the bed it's
very very hard it's not quite so
enthusiastic oh oh do you got one
that's the inner monologue that i
imagine
is going on in the corner i'll stop them
in a
minute we are going to focus on the
early dancing career of mr ryan gosling
now make sense of the only video you
have tonight is yeah yeah
so the dance troupe you were in can you
tell us about it because apparently
young dancers they can be quite vicious
it's a cutthroat business
and i had to get out
i i was on some
kind of uh canadian star search and uh i
somehow made it to the finals and uh my
main competition were these two
uh twins who were tap dancers and they
were dancing to phil collins uh two
hearts
and they had big heart-shaped bows and
they were just
they were the ones to beat so
i remember uh you know wishing them luck
and going on stage and i was getting
ready to start was dancing the everybody
dance now by cnc music factory of course
and i'm getting ready to start which is
this is how you started a winning dance
number if you want to know
get out of your hand tonight
and i look up into the into the
just off stage and the two twins are
standing there like the
twins from the shining
and they're just going like this
[Applause]
i just shimmied my way all the way to
to that trophy to that tiny little
trophy
because i i was gonna is this the same
dream i was gonna say it's an all it's
an all-girl troupe but obviously it's
not you're in it right but but
you are the only boy in it yeah that was
the was that the that was the point that
was the gimmick they let me dance there
for free because i was a guy because if
you had a guy you you would win
oh okay yeah so are you ready to see the
the
dance stylist
uh i believe you're dancing to kathy
dennis's classic touch me um uh did the
troupe have a name ryan
it was elite dance studio
and how old are you in this one
old enough to know better
enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
i wish i could say someone said here you
have to wear this
but that was my idea i thought i have a
vision for this number
and silver hammer pants they are the
silver hammer plants are i don't think
we know we gave them enough of a shot we
gave up with hammer but i don't i think
we should we should have kept them going
no yeah
[Music]
you